abone ol
bu herşeyi konuşulduğu Bana da bir şey
kalmadı benim de müzikten teknolojiden
isteyecek uçaklarından beni etkileyen
bir şey var ben bir şeyi geçmiş zaman
kuşağın dayım
abone ol
O benim çocukluğumda köyde 5 anneyiz
kanı vardı o at arabası vardı başka bir
şey yoktu Bizim içerisinde yoktu
ama biz 8 kardeşiz köyde doğduk büyümeye
çalıştık
bu sırtımıza taşıyorduk her şeyi tarlaya
ya Ya gerçekten boşluklar çok kötü
ben size ben hiç görmüyorum o yüzden
zaman kaybetmeyin ha çok güzel oldu
gerçekten hani böyle karanlığa kurşun
sıkmak diye bir şey vardır ya ya da
Karanlık odada Kara Kedi yakalamak gibi
yemiş izleyenler var da sen görmediğin
sana bir şey anlatacağım gelmiyor Kusura
bakma Sağ ol afiyet O zamanı
geçirmiyorum Çünkü benim hayat çok uzun
Sağ ol Vallahi kısa kimsenin hemen
başladı mı
ama yani böyle tırnak Çapa orası ne
varsa sırtımıza tarla taşıyoruz akşama
kadar çalışıyoruz o elde ettiğimiz
ürünleri çuvalları torbaları koyuyoruz
yine sırtımıza getiriyoruz o Alet edevat
satarlar büyükler içine girmiyoruz ama
böyle yıllar geçiyor babam güneşe kaldım
Vallahi traktör almış gibi
ne yiyeceğimizi suyumuzu bize eşeğe
semer bekliyoruz işte küçük eve şeytan
Mahallesi döküyoruz eşekten gidiyoruz
taksici beşikte gidiyoruz
ne gelmişti değil de bir de beni Fi
tarihinden geliyorum ben herşeyimizde
yapıyoruz tek bir şansımız vardı okumak
bu köydeki Hayat yürümeye başladığınız
andan itibaren başlar önce tavuk cücükcü
Civcivlere cücük derler söylerdi de
onları beslerseniz biraz büyüdüm kaz
ördek keçi koyun derken inek sığır
onlarla beraber işe attınız başlar ve
bunları çok ciddi olmak zorundasınız
Çünkü hayvanlar kaybolabilir kurs
kapanıyor Kaya'dan düşebilir ve doymadan
gelebilir daha da yavru olabilir yavru
kaybeden yavrusunu takabilirsiniz Yani
ben küçük İrem daha yürümeye başladı
inanılmaz bizi sizin içindesiniz yağmur
yağabilir sel gelebilir hayvanlarda
koyacaksınız Hatta yağmur ne zaman
yağacak mı da tamir edeceksiniz Çünkü
öyle de Beklerken Yağmur yağacak mı diye
bekledim sevgiliyiz başka bir yere
yazdım ki ya biz bunları yaşadık derken
tek şansımız okumaktı köyde yaşamanın
ikinci bir alternatif yok yani ben buyum
Mısır fasulye ettim de ya olmazsa bir
daha girme şansımız yok email
ne geliyor her şeyi bir atasözü varmış
da ben yeni duydum Hayat bir gündür o da
bugündür gidiyor
Ama sen Köyde hayat Birgün oda o tohumu
ek sinekliğin geçeceğini hepsi belirir
Yarın içeriz diye bir şansın diyorsun
yarın yağmur yağıyor fırtına olur buğday
kendisi dökülür armutlardan dökülür
elmalar yerin dibine düşer hayvanların
kaybolacağım her gün ölçülü biçimli
hesaplanmış kitapların her şeyi zamanda
yapılacak Ben köyde var ya böyle hayvan
gibi çalışacağım gerçek söyleyelim bir
fan içerdim şey başka şansımız yoktu
Yani başka şansımız yoktu
bu tırpan böyle alıp da buğday böyle bir
salladım ıtalıan yarısı gidiyordu Bir de
deste içmek diye bir şey vardır ve
tırpan sallarsın burada yönünde
toplarsın bu ayağımızda taşıyorsun
önünde Böyle yorumlar onu da bize bir
bastırsın sürü devam edersin çok da
yaylan atıldım hayvan gitmektedir benim
g***** sür koyun-keçi vallahi
Ama sen izle beslenmiş gelir nerede
Otlar nerede armut bak nerede sular
nerede Gölet var Bir gün Annem dedi ki
kızım dedi hayvanların Hani atıkları var
ya gübre Ümit ediyoruz'' dedi onları
dedi böyle bir şey yapmak için tezek yap
dedi lazım olursun dedi
ve o hayvan atıklarını aradan topladım
zamanla karıştırdım ayağımda çiğnerim
çiğnenirim bizim böyle bir taş duvar var
şimdi saçlara tezek yapıyorum yuvarlak
yuvarlak tepside yapıp buraya
yapıştırıyorum O nasıl baksın olmazsa
Ersever kaç göz yaptım Kara kaşı kara
gözü Gülen gülmeyen biri çubuklardan
kulak giderken ve duvar böyle bir
kalabalık bir aile oldu öyle kurudu
her yerinde oynama kızım diyor işte
şeylere de bak ördeklerde suya gitti
telki kapar diye Ben böyle vuralım
hoşuma gitti gergin değişik şekiller
yapıyorum tekniklerden Bugün babam da
bu Muhtarlığı aynı zamanda beni
siyasetlerini yakındı köye Kaymakam
geldi Bir de Havza'da bir milletvekili
varmış ve tanımayız da onlar geldi çocuk
çocuk yuvası bir Benim de Zekeriya
Merkezi resim çekiliyor Sen de bunu niye
söyledin Ben de güzelsiniz ya da alkış
ama zaman kaybetmedik babam bize geldi
ki küçük babam Romatizma hastası oldu
Çok çalışamaz anneyi çalışmadı Biz biraz
sekizkardeş İnanmaz çalışıyorsun babam
şaşırmayacağım yüzük anneme kalıyor bir
işi pieces yapıyorsanız en iyisini yapın
derdi ki o işi Sizin yaptığınız belli
olsun bana derdi ki yaptığın işi görev
Yağmur bak İyi yapmışsın dedin
bu hem böylesine bir gerçekten en
şerefli tarihine geçmiş zaman ve başı
uzak Derelerden Su getiriyoruz hem uydur
uydur yapıyor bizim köylüler 21
seyrediyor belki koyuyorsun geliyor yine
böyle Köyde kimse olmadığı zaman elime
çap aldım Balta Testere gittim Bir sürü
kala karşımıza kendimizi Norman
kesmiyoruz kaba kim yasak zaten onları
Kesin Kesin kesin çarşıda Kızım siz eşek
yapma bilirmisin söyle de eşek beni beni
çıkıyorsun çıkıyorsun Nevin ağzını böyle
alıyorsun eşekten daha çıkıyorsun biraz
açalım mı o zaten bacakları eşek gibi
üçgen piramit iyice kumaş akıllı orası
böyle geldi doldu ben Güzeldi Biz belki
yaptım onkum dolunca
bu yükseldi kanalda yaptım bahçesi geldi
ama Hiç sesini çıkarma kimse bilmiyor
zor ya Bahar geldi yaz geldi bahçede su
akıyor benden başka herkes O belli Ben
yaptım
ve yine böyle benzer Köprüler bir şeyler
yaptım derken büyüdük Köyde hayat
konuşma ile başlıyor niye diyeceksiniz
yine clary Sinek ısırığı kaçar Her biri
bir tarafa koş Arsel gelir kaçarsın
köpek kovalar koşarsın yana hayat
Ya ben şimdi buradaki arkadaşlar gibi
Profesör almıyım Hoş geldiniz olamadım
var ama meraklıyım Hayat al ve Avcı
işçisi ile başlıyor al avcık yakacaksın
ya koyacağım
mı başka şansı yok Öyle olunca konuşma
genlerimizde var şimdi bazen
O sizin telif programda giriyorum
Avrasya maraton koşmuş yarım saat
anlatıyor ya çok büyük Müslüm bir
şekilde koşmak bir şey değil sakın sakın
beni bir şey yapıyor zannetmiyorum
Bu koşmakla bir şey yapmıyoruz Çünkü
koşmaya canlı mı var
İyi ki
en yeni sade 60 kilometre giden Ayılar
var saatte 60 kilometre yağıyor
abone ol
Ne dersiniz koşarak Ne yaptınız
zannediyoruz ki
var ya hadi vermiyor işte bugün diyo
oyun kilometre Bir saat 10 dakikada
geldim Vallahi bir atasözü var bir bit
bir gecede 7 yatak dolaşmış Yani
gerçekten koşarak bir şey yapmış değil
ancak ha diyeceksin niye koydunuz
mecburen koştu şöyle ben okudum Öğretmen
Okulu kazandım orada uzun anlatmıyorsun
zaman çok az kaldı masa tenisi oynadı
Türkiye şampiyonu voleybol oynadım
futbol oynadım tenis oynadı mı an senin
benzeri aldım mı Benim bir keşif ruhum
var böyle köyde köyde bildim ya Dağların
Arkasını arkasına Kızım merak ederken
bile bir kaftan arkası bir hikaye vardı
Ve bu haftası aradım hep kaftan arkasını
önünü görmek istedim ama Hikayem İş
Merkezi nasıl Kafkas varmış
ya ben bu hikayeden yola çıkarak hep
inek güzelken Keşke güzeli o da arkası
merak ettim modern nereye gidiyor derken
okuduk öğretmen oldum yiyecek malzeme
Maraş'ta herkes İstanbul'a geldim
Avrasya Maratonu koştum yarı maraton 100
metre 200-400 8511
bu veya koşuyorum kulüplerde koşuyorum
sonra bir gün bir arkadaşın yabancı
ülkedeki bir arkadaşının tavsiyesiyle en
Türkiye'de ilk defa ben Hollanda'da 120
TL Ultra maraton koştum baktım çok iyi
biraz benim köye arasına benziyor
Ormanlardan zalimlerden Tepelerden
yaşıyor ayrı güzel Tam benim şey için
yol yarışı Sadece yolda geçiyor yani bu
tam benlik bir şey sonra 24 saat koştum
Çek Cumhuriyeti burada dünya
dördüncülüğü var 24 saati saati 178
kilometre var yazıyorum değil mi
hem de her şey Yaşı kalkışırsanız da
değişiyor sonra 48 saat konuştum 240
kilometre Bir şey demedi İtalyan arenada
yüz kilometre 8 saatte koştur yaşamıyor
dünya 3'üncüsü olduk Ben bunu iyi sonra
macera yarısı diye bir yere götürdüler
beni şu yarışma gelir misin dedi bir
arkadaş zannediyorum bisikletin
bisikletin var bana verdiler koşuyoruz
bir sistem iniyoruz yüzüyoruz kanal
yapıyoruz iple çıkıyor zaten o benim
işim köyde işim
var ya Bu da iyiymiş dedim Kanal D'ye
gittik Fransa gittik Çek Cumhuriyeti
Polonya derken Patagonya dünya
şampiyonasına katıldık dünya üçüncülüğü
miz var
var ya yine de bir eksik var
sen gel ben köydeki yaşanmış bir de
bulamadım
bu derken ve çöl yarışları gördüm ben
çok uğraştım çok uğraştım kadar süre
gittim cebinde böyle kuruş kuruş para
biriktirerek ten kalan içeriğinde 250
kilometreyi
ben koştum deli olsun Ne yapıyorsun
yazdım Hani bir kişi bunları ya sonra
anladım ki ben dünyayı koşarak keşfedin
biliyor musun
ya hani o güzel merakım vardı Her yeri
görmeyi Tamam dedim bu Ultra maraton
benlik
bu ne fayda koştum şimdi koştum
Tayvan'da koştum Türkiye'deki dağları
koştum neredeydin abi ben koştum
bu pası koştum abla birşeyin koştum bu
sene dört dakikam var da ondan sonra
alırsınız
bu yad edince ben şirketleri konuşmalar
yapıyorum böyle diyorum ya benim
anlatacağım Bir şey be koşup koşup
duruyor bende diyeceksiniz Benim hedefim
koşupta derece yapmak falan filan değil
koşuya araç dünyayı keşfetmek Amaç
bu iş bize bir konuşmaya çağırdım yurt
dışından bir konuşmacı getirdiler O da
böyle büyük büyük adamlar sizlerden
bir şey ne dedi
mı geldi sadece çalışın dedi döndü geri
geldi çok çalışın dedi
Ve arkasından bir soru sordular dediler
ki siz hayatta ne olmak isterdiniz O da
dedi ki Ben hayatımda tek amacım vardı
dünyanın her yerini görmek güzel cevap
fazla dilersen bilgisayar uğraş mısınız
evet dedi Bunun için yaptım dedi ben
bilgisayarı yaptım bunu anlatmak için
her gün Beni çağırdılar dedim
Eğer benimle konuşmak dünyayı keşfetmek
için aracımızı
var ya çok popüler bir şey yapmış
değilim ama bunu yapabilmek için her şey
yap ya şu koşarak dünyayı dolaşmak için
her şeyi yaptım Bu yıl Taklamakan Çölü
baştan sona geçmeye hedefledim 1450
kilometre olaylar çıktı gidemedim
arkasından Ekim Kasım aylarına Avusturya
sözünü boyda mı yetişeyim dedim yangın
çıktı şimdi projemize gramla Çünkü bazı
var diyorum bakmasın Sağ ol teşekkür
ederim inan ki bu kadarına gerek yok şu
anda çıksanız yola Çünkü genimizde var
bir Çiftlik şuradan arkadaşım sevdiğiniz
anı
bu bitireceğim de sağ ol ben konuşmayan
Canlı olmaz Bunu herkes yapabilir ama
neyi niçin yaptığımızı be bunun ne
şekilde yapabileceğinizi hangi disiplin
bazı keşiflerinden fedakarlık
edeceksiniz daha az olacaksınız Belki
sevdiğinize daha zaman arayacaksınız
daha az zaman arayacaksınız da al para
alacaksınız bak size Yeminle söylüyorum
ben bir yıldan beri ayağıma çorabı
alıyorum sporcu arkadaşlarını aşık
oluyorum
bak Bak ciddi söylüyorum geziyorum ben
şehre gidiyorum şunu bana verir misin
tepe lambası arkadaşım ben derken
düşüyorum takımı
o Çünkü benimde hedefim var ve ben o
gram nasıl konuşacağım Sağol sağol ben
çok teşekkür ediyorum Bana bu fırsatı
verdiğiniz ya bu Kurşun faydası var daha
gitmişim lan Geçmiş kitap yazdım ya
sen bana çok faydası oldu Neden Çünkü de
siz bir başarı gösteriyorsanız kimse
sizin güzelliğinizi ayakkabımızı
markasına telefonunuza işte makyajınız
var saçınıza yüz yapın zayıf bakmaz
sizin başladı sabahlar yani 10 başladı
direkt direkt kimlik oluşur Ben köyün
Havza'nın dinle köyünün de dağdaki
koymakta tam kaz güzel olarak pişen bir
çocukken
bu koşa koşa Afrika'nın öbürüne
Amerika'nın öbürüne Patagonya larda
kazalardan seferlerde de dünyanın öbür
ucunda koşmuş adamı Bunu bana Sağ ol
yani sadece aile disiplini ve benim
bu Türkiye Cumhuriyeti'ndeki okuma
hakkını olmasın herkeze sonsuz sevgiler
kuşun ama yollarda değil hayatınızın
peşinde sevdiklerinizin peşinde
çocuklarınızın peşinde